here we had this new epidemic that was
announced the world on June the 5th 1981
and nobody knew how bad it was we knew
it was bad we knew it was terrible but
nobody knew quite how bad it was we knew
that because of this cascade of
infections in Australia we and other
countries we knew that it had to be
stopped
among people who inject drugs otherwise
it would reach out to the general
community
my colleagues and I suggested let's do a
needle syringe program and all our
critics said no no you can't do that you
mustn't do that
nobody said don't do that do this
instead they just said no you can't do
that and we did it
since 1988 in this country we've been
giving clean injecting equipment to drug
users and we've been doing that because
of the health mandate that says whether
or not we approve whether or not we like
what people are doing we know what
people are doing and people are
injecting drugs and they have been for
many years and this rate it's expected
that they will be for many years much in
all as we have you know tried to stop an
activity that activity is occurring
without a needle syringe programs we
would have had a much bigger epidemic we
would have had HIV would have got into
the population of people who inject
drugs in a major way and it would have
spread to the general community as it
did in the United States
this service is a medical supervisor
injecting Center it was the first
service of its kind in the
english-speaking world when we opened in
May 2001 and basically it is a place
that a person who uses drugs who injects
drugs can come off the street and
legally inject those drugs without fear
of prosecution and they can do it in a
safe non-judgmental surroundings I think
a supervisor injecting facility is a
eminently logical eminently sensible
next step which is I know who you are
and I know what you're doing with that
equipment that I just gave you and here
I'll provide you with a roof and some
care the feedback that you get from our
clients the the single starkest most
commonly repeated phrase is thank you
for treating me like a human being
because I think that's unusual for the
people that we see I don't want to take
heroin I don't want to take cocaine or
amphetamines but if somebody else does
and doesn't want to harm any of anybody
else why do they get punished that's the
most fundamental question in this whole
issue and that's what I've spent the
last 27 years on and nowadays it's not
just me saying things like that
it's former UN Secretary General's
former Prime Minister's former presence
and now even current presence and
current prime ministers are saying that
and we're at long last seeing drug law
reform starting to happen around the
world
we now have about 70 or 80 countries
that have needle syringe programs around
the world all 27 members of the European
Union have Neil's syringe programs and
now that the epidemic of injecting drug
use is starting to spread throughout
Africa the century now is starting to
see harm reduction take root in Africa
NSP needle syringe programs have kept
the rate of HIV amongst people who
inject drugs in this country at about
one percent that is something to be
absolutely proud of and internationally
when we go to conferences something that
Australia is is very rightly acclaimed
as you know a leader in the field this
was something that you guys did
incredibly well you stopped HIV from
spreading in
the population people who inject drugs
you